I love eggs!
Where's the rum ham?
Can we maybe put
this divider up?
Well, no.
We don't want to exclude
a great man like Frank
from the conversa--
Oh my God!
Call 911!
No, it's ok. I have
a touch of consumption.
He's alright.
Why don't we
drop him off, Fiona,
and go to dinner, ok?
I think I've been poisoned
by my constituents!
Oh my God!
Can I offer you a nice egg
in this trying time?
Yeah, he's got an egg.
It might--
-What is that?
-I don't know.
That's not on the map.
What ride is that?
Excuse me? Excuse me, ma'am.
What is this ride over here?
Oh, that's our new slide.
It's Thunder Gun Express.
We just finished
construction.
It'll be open
in a few weeks.
-A Thunder Gun ride?
-Yeah.
Like the movie?
Yeah, but there's no water
or anything yet,
so we still have to test it.
-Oh, yeah.
-It's totally dry.
-Ok, yeah. Let's go!
-No, but it's not…
It's not open yet.
Thunder Gun, man.
No hesitation.
No surrender.
No man left behind.
We've got to get
to the top of that slide!
And raw-dog
the shit out of it!
Here we go!
Right, this should be good,
right?
-Oh, that's great.
-That'll do it.
Who's going first?
Well, it should be you,
right?
I mean, you pulled off
the AIDS thing.
Charlie, Charlie!
Let's go
before we get busted, ok?
-Alright, here we go.
-Alright.
-Alright, fat guy.
-I won't let you down.
Alright! Like the spirit.
It burns, it burns!
-My back!
-That man has AIDS!
Kids, everybody out!
-Frank, wake up!
-What's the matter?
Where's the beach?
Over… I don't know.
We're in the middle
of the goddamn ocean!
Yes we are!
What are we gonna do?
Well, we're going to
conk out for a while
and let the current gently
roll us back to shore.
Frank, the current is
what brought us out here
in the first place!
If anything, we should be
paddling against it
to get back to the beach!
I'm going to pretend like
I didn't hear that.
Frank, Frank.
We are no longer
in relaxing mode.
We are now in survival mode!
Will you stop being
so dramatic?
Wait a minute!
Where's the rum ham?
-What?
-Where's the rum…
Rum ham!
No, Frank! Stay in the boat!
Frank, stay in the boat!
I want rum ham!
I'm sorry, rum ham.
I'm sorry!
Rum ham…
Oh, rum ham…
You are a good shit
and I want to
make this legit.
I'm still going to pay you,
but I want you to stop
banging other guys.
What do you say?
Want to be my wife or what?
Holy shit!
Oh my God.
Oh my…
-Whoops. Christ!
-No.
It's ok. She does this
from time to time.
She's had an excessive
amount to drink, so…
Ok. Roxy, get up. Come on.
-Roxy!
-Come on, Roxy.
Big day for Frank here!
We don't have a ton of time,
Rox. Get up!
Pete, she's dead.
How could she be dead?
I'm telling you.
Her heart popped.
She was smoking crack in
the car the whole way here
and also all day long.
She's got no pulse.
-Oh my God!
-Holy shit.
Call 911!
-Call an ambulance!
-Yeah.
-Jesus…
-No, no!
-What?
-I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Wait. We've got to think
this through, ok?
A dead hooker
in my apartment?
That doesn't look good
for me.
I'm covered in blood.
I mean…
It's not good to have
a dead hooker, right?
It would kind of mess up our
second acts a little bit
and I'll tell you guys
something.
I smoked a little crack
in the car on the way over.
Oh, you bitch!
Oh, does she still have any?
-We can't leave her here!
-Well, no.
We can't leave her here.
Let's…
Ok, well, I mean…
I don't want to sound
insensitive,
but we could just put her
out in the hall.
We call in an anonymous tip.
-We're still calling 911.
-Someone will find her.
From a pay phone.
This seems like
the best thing to do
considering
the circumstances.
Frank, what do you think?
I think Roxy would have
wanted it that way.
-He would know.
-Well, there you go.
-Frank would know.
-I mean, that's it.
I'd like to say a few words.
Make it nice. Let's make
the whole thing nice.
Really? I just want to
get her out of here.
Oh, nice.
Roxy, God bless you.
You were a good whore.
You serviced me like
no other whore ever did.
Not only my crank,
but my heart.
And… I'm gonna miss you.
Amen.
Now, Charlie and I,
we go down the sewer
and, first thing we do is,
to preserve our clothes,
we take our clothes off.
We get totally naked.
Because you don't want to
get wet.
We ball our clothes up.
We stick them up
some place high.
Once I pooped in the bed.
I blamed it on him!
One time, the guys
got hooked on crack.
It was really crazy.
Well, they found a baby
in a dumpster.
They wanted to make
some money with the baby,
but nobody would buy the
baby because it was white.
They thought
they had to turn it brown.
We were fighting
over the sword
and, just about
when we were about to
hit each other
with the sword,
social services came in
and thought
we were killing the baby.
I don't understand
this tour.
Charlie wrote this musical.
Oh, man.
It was really funny.
I play a troll
in the musical.
-A troll?
-Yeah.
And it's called
The Night Man Cometh.
I can sing you my song,
if you like.
-Let it go, man.
-You've go to…
You've got to pay
the troll toll
to get into this boy's hole.
He say he pay toll
to enter boy's hole!
I was saying… soul.
He was saying… He thought
I was saying boy's hole.
You came at the right time!
-Is he sleeping?
-Yes.
He's sleeping
right over there.
Just the way you like him.
Did you bring the toll?
Confound your lousy toll,
troll!
Goddamn it.
Stop laughing at me.
You've got to pay
the troll toll
if you want to
get into that boy's hole
You've got to pay
the troll toll to get in
You want the baby boy's hole
You've got to pay
the troll toll
the troll toll to get in
Troll toll
What do you say?
Hey, hey, hey
Troll toll
-Hello!
-Hello?
I'm Gogar Blogian,
the art collector.
-Charmed, I'm sure.
-Yes.
I'm going to invite you
to a show.
Ok.
But, first, allow me to
destroy your gallery.
Bullshit.
Derivative.
That…
I love, I absolutely love.
That's just
the air conditioner.
I want it.
It's everything.
I mean, look at us.
We're just air conditioners.
I mean, after all,
we're just walking around
on the planet breathing,
conditioning the air.
-Right.
-I condition it hot.
That conditions it cold.
I mean, it's symbiotic.
-No?
-No, it is.
We're just
the air conditioners
walking around
on this planet
screwing each other's brains
out.
So true. I never
thought of it like that.
Next thing you know,
I was Shanghaid upstate
to a nitwit school.
You know
what a nitwit school is?
I assume you mean a school
for the mentally disabled.
Yeah.
Not just for nuts
in the head.
Bodies, too.
Back then,
science was real crude.
They stuck us all together.
My roommate was a frog kid.
You ever see a frog kid?
A frog kid?
Yeah.
The place was windowless.
There was a guard
every ten feet.
All the rooms had drains
in the floors
so they could hose us down.
How terrible!
I got my first kiss there.
Frank?
It was terrible.
But not her.
She was an angel.
Always smiling.
That's because
she had no lips.
But her mouth was
still very much in play.
Let's talk about the dishes.
She died two weeks later.
She thought
she was a spaceman
with a plastic bag
for a helmet.
I unzipped me!
It's all coming back.
I hate you!
Frank Reynolds.
Oh, yeah. We were just
talking about him.
-He's the worst, huh?
-Right?
Do you work here?
-Yeah, of course. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-Well, we pop around.
-We pop around here.
-We're consultationists…
-for this.
So we consult here.
We consult
across the street, too.
Across the whole street.
Is there a man
in that couch?
What are you saying?
A man in a couch?
-Hello?
-That's absurd!
I believe there's a man
in that couch right there.
There is no man.
There's no man.
Say some things
about Frank Reynolds.
Say them loud and make sure
that they're horrible things
and then we'll deal with
the man in the couch.
Ok, so there is a man
in the couch.
Alright, just call Frank
Reynolds an arsehole.
Who is Frank Reynolds?
He's the man in the couch!
Oh my God.
What are you people doing?
Will you just say something
about Frank that's horrible?
-Call him an arsehole!
-Frank is an arsehole!
Oh, thank you!
Oh, great. Now you've…
Oh, Jesus Christ!
Oh, no. Oh, no.
What is happening?
Can't breathe!
-Too hot!
-You're naked, Frank!
It's too hot.
Leather couch.
Ok, but did you hear
she called you an arsehole?
She called you an arsehole,
Frank!
No air. No air.
What the hell is this?
Oh, shit.
I think it's hand sanitiser.
-Hand sanitiser?
-Where's it going?
Frank?
Why is there hand sanitiser
all over the floor?
It goes in here.
Oh!
-Frank?
-Oh my God.
What the hell
did you do to yourself?
I just wanna be pure.